ça fait longtemps que je me suis dit oh
mais j'aimerais faire travailler dans le
vieux port de montréal la chasse à
l'emploi est commencé pour ce tour son
premier choix s'est arrêté sur le centre
des sciences de montréal qui tient deux
journées de recrutement j'aimerais le
pote de maritime ça ferait un nouveau
défi des jamais fait cela et les offres
que j'ai vu sur le tableau ça vraiment
intéressante 80 postes sont à pourvoir
pour l'été temps chargé des animateurs
scientifiques ont cherché technicien
multimédia on cherche des agents biétry
le centre des sciences a souffert de la
pandémie il accueillera les touristes
cet été une première en deux ans déclare
que les employés ont bougé on dit à
trouver d'autres plans et de travail
donc maintenant c'est à nous de faire la
démonstration à quel point c'est un bon
plan de travail de venir nous rejoindre
pour travailler avec nous c'est terry on
n'est ce pas que c'est vraiment la
saison estivale la relance une trentaine
d'entreprises touristiques tiennent des
journées de recrutement car on estime à
40 mille le nombre de postes vacants
dans l'industrie déjà pour avoir des
craintes en disant ah ouais mais c'est
presque un secteur fragile pas du tout
c'est un secteur qui eut un coup de
vagues mais c'est un secteur solide
secteur plein potentiel qui est en forte
croissance avant la pandémie donc pas
d'hésitation mais force est de constater
que les défis sont nombreux avant c'est
l'employeur qui choisissait un employé à
travers un bassin employés
là c'est l'employé avait un bassin
d'emploi ya trois personnes
et devant trop de postes à combler
croisait rae maile doit se tourner vers
le recrutement à l'étranger et coûteux
c'est un processus qui est très long
mais on ne plus le choix parce que bébé
parce qu'ils ne se comble plus ici de
nombreux étudiants ont répondu à l'appel
du zoo de granby mais là aussi il faut
trouver plus de personnel ont été bougés
d'embauché de plus de personnes parce
qu'ils veulent faire un peu moins dans
pas tout temps de 40 ans pas trop des
grandes jambes journée et avoir une
possibilité de profiter plus que jamais
l'industrie touristique doit faire
preuve de créativité de jeunes retraités
ont aussi été appelés en renfort pour
cet été quoi qu'il en soit tous les
acteurs sont unanimes la prochaine
saison estivale en sera une grande de
relance ici qui me permettra au canada
montréal